qu'on parle de star wars et nos
personnages préférés on cite souvent
obi-wan yoda anakin voire même jar jar
binks et on parle très rarement des
stormtroopers et pourtant ces
personnages sont peut-être les plus
complets et les plus complexes
psychologiquement de toute la saga
on peut admirer luxe les rockeurs pour
sa bravoure en solo pour ses sketchs de
pilotes encore palpatine pour son génie
du mal les stormtroopers généralement
quand on en parle c'est plutôt pour se
moquer de leur maladresse ou leur
inutilité dans les intrigues par exemple
mais ce qu'ils sont si nul que ça qu'on
les trouve si inintéressant et son a
cependant les combats regardant la
prière théologie manque tout en leur
cible
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on a vu plus efficace
surtout quand on sait que chaque
stormtrooper reçoit un entraînement
intensif est extrêmement poussée lors de
sa formation est également équipé d'une
désarmés ont le plus avancé de la
galaxie à mes ongles inde est composé de
18 éléments indépendants casque
perfectionner avec filtre respiratoire
en vision infrarouge systèmes de
communications longue distance et
détecteur de mouvement intégré une
ceinture de munitions
1 comme link un grappin en détonateurs
thermique et un fusil blaster
on part sur un équipement de type plutôt
lourd 1 et en plus ils composent l'armée
la plus redoutée de tous univers un an
par thème de plusieurs millions voire
milliards de combattants a servi par les
plus grands puissances maléfiques de la
galaxie et si finalement il ne parvenait
pas à tirer correctement sur leur cible
parce qu'il n'avait pas envie de le
faire une étude américaine sur la
seconde guerre mondiale a montré
qu'entre 80 et 85% des soldats
n'utilisait pas leurs armes sur le champ
de bataille
la raison en fait c'était trop dur pour
eux de tuer un autre humain une fois
qu'ils étaient en face les stands
foubert vous pourrez me dire c'est pas
vraiment de juin donc ça devrait - les
gêner oui et non là je vais mini sprint
les star wars un jeu diminue parce que
c'est pas très important et que ça
concerne que les stormtroopers mais pour
rappel ils sont à la base d'une armée de
clones d'un seul et même homme
le chasseur de primes jango fett ils ont
été créés par les habitants la planète
kamino et commander secrètement par
l'empereur palpatine pour en faire une
armée redoutable capable d'anéantir les
jedi alors je résume la situation au
maximum 1 pour simplifier la narration
de cet épisode
mais n'hésitez pas du tout à voir les
films pour plus de détails du coup voilà
il devient l'armé officiel de l' empire
c'est le gros méchant et se font
remplacer petit à petit par des vrais
humains parce que les clones
vieillissait trop vite et devenait trop
cher à entretenir
et là ça devient intéressant si on
regarde ça d'un point de vue
psychologique on a des soldats humains
qui prennent la place de clown serre qui
remplace une personne sans aucune
individualité et conçu dans le seul but
d'être un stormtrooper pour n'est pas
trop dans l'épanouissement personnel et
je fais à sec il faut qu'ils soient tous
habillés pareil sans aucune distinction
ah oui le code vestimentaire en fonction
des classes moi je te parle de tout sans
peur de base pour tous sans casque
identiques quelle est leur vrai visage
et qui les rend tous semblables
d'ailleurs ils n'ont pas le droit
d'amendement au passage c'est peut-être
aussi à cause de ça qu'il n'arrive pas à
tirer dans
non ça va pas être évident en plus de ça
ils n'ont pas de nom prénom on les
appelle par un matricule fait de
chiffres et de lettres
voilà donc toute leur identité leur
singularité leur passé est oublié
au moins ils font leur entrée dans
l'armée de l'empiré donc en fait
l'identité d'un centre hooper et
s'arrête là où son armure commence mais
c'est plus qu'une paire de singularité
dont on parle c'est une perte d'humanité
on pourrait presque parler de
déshumanisation extrême la
déshumanisation c'est un concept
philosophique assez moderne et pourtant
ils datent déjà de 1907 avec henri
bergson qui fut l'un des premiers
philosophes à aborder le sujet alors lui
pour le coup il le ferait dans une autre
optique que ce qui nous intéresse
directement ici puisque il nous explique
que la race humaine
elle s'efface au profit des identités
technologiques les outils priment sur
ceux qui les utilisent les grandes
lignes que nous retiendrons l'humanité
seront celles liées aux évolutions
technologiques
par exemple on n'a pas rentrer la
naissance de l'homme à celle du feu ou
des premières armes et dans de milliers
d'années
on retiendra davantage la création de la
machine à vapeur que certaines guerres
que l'homme a pu mener pour lui en fait
l'homme s'efface au profit de la
technologie
en revanche là où ça nous touche plus
directement c'est la vision d'une autre
philosophe française simone veil elle
elle voit notre monde comme un monde
inversé où l'humain n'est plus vraiment
à sa place avec l'apparition du travail
à la chaîne et la naissance de la
bureaucratie
elle partage sa peur de voir l'homme
devenir une simple pièce
interchangeables et remplaçables d'une
immense machine il ne se définit plus
par sa personnalité mais par son rôle et
tu ce qui fait de lui un homme pour
devenir une chose et ça rappelle nos
amis sur le trooper un travail subissent
un entraînement intensif pour devenir
ces nouveaux soldats
c'est ce processus poussée à son extrême
qui se produit l'emplir ce régime
totalitaire
non c'est pas le genre du service
militaire ou 7 des colonnes à mon avis
tu vois c'est un enseignement dur une
scie pline de faire des règles strictes
et les mecs deviennent des armes à part
entière on leur fait oublier d'où ils
viennent
on leur bousculent leurs notions de bien
et de mal du coup va tuer des innocents
qui c'est un membre et qu'on est
conditionné pour y obéir quoi ne pas le
faire un psychologue américain a déjà
tenté d'apporter une réponse à cette
question si stanley milgram qui s'est
rendu célèbre avec sa fameuse expérience
de milgram
ce qui fait un kilo en gros un
scientifique ordonne à un sujet
d'infliger des décharges électriques à
un inconnu installé dans une pièce
voisine
s'il se trompe lors d'un test de
mémorisation le sujet dicte des séries
de mots à retenir à l'inconnu et vérifie
ses réponses
une erreur égale une décharge électrique
les charges augmentent au fur et à
mesure et à chaque erreur le
scientifique incite le sujet a déclenché
la décharge en tout cas c'est comme ça
que c'est présenté au sujet on lui fait
croire que c'est ça qui se passe et
qu'il a été recruté pour participer à
une expérience visant à vérifier tes
capacités d'apprentissage
sauf que ce qui ne sait pas c'est que
c'est lui le cobaye et la personne dans
l'autre pièce c'est un acteur qui ne
reçoit aucune charge en réalité ils et
simule juste le scientifique dans n'est
pas un non plus c'est un autre acteur à
qui on a foutu une blouse blanche et le
but de l'expérience est de voir jusqu'où
peut aller l'obéissance d'un sujet à une
autorité qui pensent légitime ici du
coup c'est le mec déguisé en
scientifique et analyser son processus
de soumission à cette même autorité
alors gelé vachement synthétiser un ca
se décompose en réalité un an plusieurs
paliers et le scientifique dana chaque
fois des ordres des indications
différentes
il ya plein de variantes soit si ça vous
intéresse n'hésitez pas à me demander
d'en faire un coup de fil dans les
commentaires quoi qu'il en soit les
résultats des premières expériences
menées par milgram sont impressionnants
sur 40 sujets y en a 25 qui vont au bout
du processus
en affichant à trois reprises des
simulations des charges de 450 volts ce
qui est violent
simplement par soumission à une entité
qui leur semblait légitime et qui leur
demandait de le faire déjà à l'époque
milgram avait qualifié ces résultats
d'inattendu et un piéton
ça fait un peu froid dans le dos
maintenant repenser à nos amis
stormtrooper et imaginer leur degré
d'obéissance et de soumission pour agir
d'une telle manière envers des
populations entières d'innocents en plus
avec leurs casques ils peuvent tirer sur
autrui sans que l'on puisse voir leur
vrai visage et vous savez mieux que
personne dans l'anonymat c'est plus
facile de faire du mal coucou l'espace
commentaire non je plaisante en vrai
j'ai beaucoup de chance et la plupart du
temps que vous êtes extrêmement gentil
avec moi
enfin gros bisous est-ce que ça les
déresponsabilise complètement pour
autant non parce que je dis et c'est une
question autrement plus complexe qui
implique quelques pas aussi qu'on se
pose la question de l'existence de libre
arbitre
mais dans tous les cas ça permet quand
même de remettre un petit peu les choses
en perspective alors la prochaine fois
pour faire un stormtrooper tiré dans le
vide
ne me dites pas que c'est un bon à rien
ou que son blaster a été fabriqué en
chine
déjà parce que la chine se n'existe pas
dans star wars non mais vous plutôt que
derrière ce casque se cache peut être un
individu déshumanisé sans identité
endoctrinés et soumis en train de
remettre toute son existence en question
et si vous lâchez un spoil seront
gwangju bloc de la chaîne mais avec
amour j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
plu donc voilà il ya eu la sortie de
rock one c'était un petit peu l'occasion
de faire
didot sur star wars et le format qui se
prête le plus c'est les popups d'autres
personnages et d'autres trucs dans star
wars sur lequel on peut partir un petit
peu en philo en psycho en tout ce que
vous voulez donc voilà c'est toujours
une mine inépuisable
j'espère que ça vous a plus c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas le partager et si vous
n'êtes pas abonnés à la chaîne et par
abonné vous pour pas rater les futurs
vidéo aussi monsieur sur facebook
twitter c'est un chat je dis à chaque
fois parce que à chaque fois c'est tout
aussi important
tout ne se passe pas que sur youtube
même s'il se passe beaucoup de choses
sur youtube tout ne se passe pas que sur
you tube love peace